dalida et mortelle trouvait solitude
insupportable dans ce journal une
édition spéciale consacrée à dalida
georges marchais à moscou le secrétaire
général du parti communiste rencontre
monsieur gorbatchev son compagnie maxime
gremetz et andré lajoinie le roi du
maroc hassan ii et le président algérien
chadli bendjedid se sont rencontrés à
oujda l'est du maroc pour désamorcer la
tension entre leurs deux pays à propos
du sahara occidental avec une médiation
saoudienne
aujourd'hui lundi 4 mai 1987 nouvelle
journée de détention pour les otages
français au liban
marcel fontaine et marcel carton jean
paul kauffmann et jean louis normandin
d'antenne 2 n'ont toujours pas été
libérés
bonsoir dalida était chanteuse
comédienne elle avait 54 ans elle s'est
suicidé hier dans sa maison de
montmartre à paris
la vie m'est insupportable pardonnez moi
c'est le message laissé par dalida et
dans quelques minutes avec guy lux
nicoletta hervé vilard le directeur de
l'olympia jean michel boris et youssef
chahine avec des témoignages des
extraits de ses films et de ses chansons
eh bien nous évoquerons la carrière et
la vie de dalida
la dernière fois qu'elle vainc
quarantaine de sté ici dans ce journal
c'était pour la sortie du film le
sixième jour de youssef chahine
écoutez la chanson
j'invente
m
l'essai
non
on retrouve dalida dans quelques minutes
avec une édition spéciale qui sera
consacrée dans une semaine au palais de
justice de lyon spécialement aménagée
s'ouvrira le procès de klaus barbie ce
soir sur antenne 2 à 21h40 dans le
magazine caméra de nous vous proposerons
un reportage réalisé en bolivie au pérou
et au brésil par daniel leconte le
ministre de l'intérieur bolivien qui
arrêta klaus barbie témoigne et à
l'appui de son témoignage
un document inédit l'arrivée de barbie
dans les locaux du ministère de
l'intérieur bolivien à la base barbie ne
sait pas qu'il va partir pour la france
nous sommes en 1983 voici ce document
exclusif
cette scène muette a été filmée par un
fonctionner un bolivien et conservés
dans un coffre fort elle n'a jamais été
diffusée jusqu'à ce jour 4 février 83 la
vie de klaus barbie hommes libres
s'arrête ici à la passe en bolivie dans
les locaux du ministère de l'intérieur
dernière étape de barbie avant son
expulsion vers la france
menottes aux poignets barbie est conduit
sous escorte policière dans une pièce
puis soumis à une mise en scène imaginée
par le secrétaire d'état à l'intérieur
du nouveau régime démocratique
gustavo sanchez barbie a le regard vide
les cheveux défaits
lui qui a vécu en toute impunité dans ce
pays ne comprends plus ce qui se passe à
ses côtés trois hommes mingo là un
argentin ami de barbie c'est un
paramilitaire qui a travaillé comme
demain à l'époque de la dictature cas si
un autre ami supposé de barbie lui les
trafiquants de drogue
enfin ou star s ex contrôleur général
une sorte de super ministre des finances
par ailleurs idéologues de l'extrême
droite bolivienne ramassées dans cette
image donc l'ensemble des activités
supposées de barbie en amérique latine
c'est ainsi que se termine la carrière
bolivienne de l'ex responsable de la
gestapo de lyon
dans quelques minutes il sera transféré
à l'aéroport de la passe
destination la france mais il ne le sait
pas encore
avec au bout la justice française ce
document daniel fait partie de votre
reportage qui s'intitule la deuxième
victoire vie c'est donc après la guerre
et avant son extradition 83 il ya des
révélations on dirait en même temps des
choses d
un peu anecdotique sont tout à fait
passionnant alors justement la règle et
de 1971 barbie se trouve en france il va
au panthéon fleuri la tombe de jean
moulin du moins c'est ce qu'il dit cette
anecdote signal à sa façon la liberté de
mouvement dont barbie a pu jouir pendant
plus de 30 ans 30 ans pendant lesquels
ils passent le plus clair de son temps
d'olive il sera tour à tour aux hommes
d'affaires truqueurs amis des
trafiquants d'armes conseiller en
répression des dictateurs bolivien et
pour finir interlocuteur privilégié de
certains terroristes d'extrême droite
qui sèment la terreur en italie à la fin
des années 70 autant d'activités qui
feront de barbie le protéger de tous
ceux qui en bolivie ont gouverné par la
force pendant des dizaines d'années
c'est donc grâce à eux mais aussi en
partie grâce aux états unis qui s'en
servent comme agent de renseignement il
grâce à la france qui savait où il se
trouvait depuis 1963 au moins que barbie
a pu couler des jours sans histoire
pendant 32 ans
de tout cela il ne sera pas question à
lyon lors du procès c'est un côté
méconnu de sa vie les un côté capital
qui à sa manière est clair le personnage
par bien des aspects la deuxième vie de
barbie ressemble à la première deuxième
vie claude barit 21h40 dans camera 2 ce
soir les principaux responsables du
parti communiste français sont à moscou
georges marchais est accompagné de
maxime gremetz et andré lajoinie ils ont
rencontré michael gorbatchev aujourd'hui
c'est la deuxième rencontre entre
messieurs marché et gorbatchev voyez le
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux moscou
henri elie marcel martin
après les habituels geste de courtoisie
à l'égard du numéro un soviétique effet
significatif georges marchais présente
andré lajoinie peut-être pas encore son
successeur à la tête du parti
mais sans doute le probable candidat du
pc aux élections présidentielles de 88
puis c'est la traditionnelle photo de
famille des deux délégations
mais aujourd'hui ni le lieu ni l'heure
ne se prêtaient tourisme les deux
secrétaires généraux des partis
communistes soviétiques et de concerts
ont parlé sans doute des rapports leur
partie de la force électorale du pcf
actuellement en france mais également de
la situation internationale
à l'ordre du jour tout d'abord les
relations franco soviétique quelque peu
tendues depuis mars dernier après l
affaire d'espionnage autour de la fusée
ariane ensuite michael gorbatchev et
george marchés vont aborder bien sûr et
c'était d'ailleurs prévu les problèmes
du nucléaire de la paix et du
désarmement
à ce propos ils ont évoqué les récentes
propositions soviétique fait aux
américains concernant le retrait des
missiles à moyenne portée
installé devant nouveau de résultats
d'élections cantonales partielles hier
ont été favorables à la gauche et au
parti socialiste élections à modane en
savoie de monsieur jean gauthier et à
delle dans le territoire de belfort de
l'ancien député et membre de la haute
autorité
raymond forni les deux groupes
sidérurgiques usinor sacilor ont accusé
en 1986 une perte nette totale de 12,5
milliards de francs la perte s'élevait à
8,7 milliards en 1985
selon le pdg des groupes cuisine heures
et sacilor la sidérurgie française ne
sortira pas du rouge avant 1990 à partir
de demain mise en place des dispositifs
arrêté par le ministre affaires sociales
philippe seguin concernant le
remboursement de toutes les dépenses de
santé certaines maladies ne seront plus
remboursés à 100%
cela pourrait concerner 3 millions de
personnes explications m mais tu es
premier point le principe il concerne
les trois millions de personnes
actuellement remboursés à 100% en raison
d'une affection longue et coûteuse
désormais la sécurité sociale ne
remboursera plus à 100% que les soins
liés directement à leur maladie se
nécessité par d'autres affections ne
seront plus remboursés coteaux
applicable à l'ensemble des assurés
sociaux 40 ou 60 15%
par exemple si vous êtes diabétique les
soins liés à votre diabète continueront
d'être remboursés à 100% mais si vous
attrapez une grippe
les soins liés à cette grippe ne le
seront qu'à 40 ou 60 15%
deuxième point l'objectif cette mesure
doit rapporter 845 millions de francs
cette année puis 1 milliard et demi de
francs par an troisième point
l'application
voici un jeu d'ordonnancé que vous avez
reçu de votre caisse si vous êtes
actuellement remboursés à 100% se fera à
vous de le présenter à votre médecin
une fois collé l'étiquette vous
concernant pour les soins liés à votre
affection longue durée
enfin si vos ressources sont inférieures
à 80 2430 francs par an vous pouvez
demander à votre caisse de bénéficier de
la gratuité pour l'ensemble de vos soins
mais cette gratuité ne sera pas accordée
systématiquement à l'est du maroc non
loin de la frontière algérienne à oujda
le roi hassan ii et le président
algérien monsieur chadli bendjedid se
sont rencontrés grâce aux bons offices
du roi fahd d'arabie saoudite cette
rencontre destinée à faire baisser la
tension entre l'algérie et le maroc à
propos du sahara commentaires philippe
gassot détails protocolaires qui en dit
long sur la tension qui existe entre
l'algérie et le maroc le tapis rouge
déroulé à même le sable devait être
installé à oujda au maroc puis en
algérie
en fait c'est exactement sur la
frontière qu'il a été foulé par hassan
ii le président algérien chadli et par
le roi fahd d'arabie venu en médiateur
il s'agit pour les trois hommes
d'essayer de trouver une solution pour
mettre un terme à la guerre menée depuis
douze ans par le polisario contre le
maroc
la dernière rencontre au sommet avait eu
lieu en 83 sans donner de résultat cette
fois le roi d'arabie que l'on dit malade
intervient en personne
le gardien des lieux saints 2
slam en pleine période de ramadan a sans
doute apporté avec lui au moins les
bauges d'une solution acceptable par les
parties en présence
la puissance financière saoudienne est
le principal soutien logistique de
l'armée marocaine un moyen de pression
qui peut être déterminant
côté polisario fort de douze à quinze
mille hommes en armes
le sommet va dans le sens souhaité si sa
conclusion donne raison aux décisions de
l'onu et de l'ua qui prône un référendum
portant sur l'autodétermination du
peuple sahraoui
dans le cas contraire il n'y aura pas de
solution c'est aussi la vie des
algériens pour le roi du maroc
il l'a déjà dit l'autodétermination est
inacceptable pour les marocains fort de
160 mille soldats la nation sahraoui est
généralement une vue de l'esprit on
parle davantage à rabat de mercenaires à
la solde d'alger qui vise les mines de
phosphate du sahara occidental avec un
encerclement du maroc ouvrant une brèche
sur l'atlantique
le sommet d'aujourd'hui aura coïncidé
avec les dernière pelletée de sable
destinés à terminer les murs anti
polisario qui protège le triangle utile
le roi fahd aura bien du mal à mettre un
terme à une guerre dont le prix dépasse
10 millions de francs par jour le roi
hussein de jordanie le président syrien
et son homologue irakien se seraient
rencontrés près d'amman en jordanie la
semaine dernière cette rencontre secrète
est annoncée par un quotidien koweïtien
et les domaines d'ailleurs américain
newsweek mais démentie par les autorités
jordaniennes
au liban le premier ministre monsieur
rachid karamé a annoncé sa démission le
clan chrétien réclamé cette démission
depuis plusieurs semaine dernière
journée de la visite du pape en
allemagne fédérale jean paul ii était
aujourd'hui à augsburg pour le pape la
réforme de luther au 16e siècle a pu
avoir des effets positifs sur l'église
catholique cette phrase oecuméniques
était beaucoup commentée en allemagne
jean-claude à rigaud
au revoir monsieur le chancelier le
dernier acte protocolaire avant le
retour vers le vatican de cette deuxième
visite de jean paul ii en rfa on
retiendra entre autres moments
importants cet instant dans la
cathédrale d'augsbourg l'un des hauts
lieux de la contestation protestante au
16e siècle ensemble aujourd'hui dans une
prière commune le pape des catholiques
et divers dignitaires protestants le
signe que les choses ont changé au pays
de lutter
il meurt au fond a dit jean paul ii la
réforme n'a pas eu que des effets
négatifs
elle a permis à l'église romaine de
marcher sur la voie de la réflexion et
du renouveau une phrase étonnante mais
qui vient bien en continuité avec
l'attitude des églises chrétiennes
depuis une vingtaine d'années et se fait
ravi d'être ainsi à nouveau reconnu les
protestants ne se sont pas contentés de
compliments ils ont demandé à jean paul
ii d'aller au delà des déclarations et
de sauver l'écumé nisme afin que le feu
allumé au concile ne se transforme pas
en cendres pour un certain nombre de
réformes et en effet les rapports entre
chrétiens catholiques et protestants
devrait déboucher sur des actions
concrètes et un dialogue dans l'égalité
toujours un peu l'impression si vous
voulez que l'église catholique pense que
bon bah il est bien que nous la suivions
si j'ose dire que ce soit elle qui ait
invité que nous répondions et c'est ce
problème de la prise au sérieux des
autres comme des partenaires à part
entière qui est peut-être le domaine
dans lequel il ya du chemin à faire
le deuxième voyage de jean-paul ii en
allemagne cinq jours se met d'embûches
le pape ne s'est pas laissé intimider il
a parlé clair et fort une question at il
convaincu
le ministre de l'intérieur s'attaque au
minitel rose au nom de la protection des
mineurs et dénonce les partis
d'opposition qui défendent de gros
intérêts financiers basés sur l'apologie
du sexe interview de monsieur pasqua
publié par la haute-marne libérer la voc
des minitel a créé une sorte de vide
juridique et monsieur pasqua a craint le
développement du proxénétisme via les
petites abus la theurre enquête pascal
stelletta aimé mayol le téléphone rose
et les messageries coquine sur minitel
sont deux façons moderne d'assouvir bien
des fantasmes pour dialoguer avec
isabelle sur minitel long tendre au
téléphone la voix suave et racoleuse de
géraldine
le tarif est le même 73 centimes toutes
les 45 secondes
il ya aujourd'hui deux millions et demi
de minitel en service les messageries
c'est à dire la possibilité de dialoguer
avec d'autres usagers représentent 16%
de l'ensemble du trafic
en tout un chiffre d'affaires de plus
d'un milliard de francs pour l'année 86
les fournisseurs de services se
partagent les deux tiers du pactole
l'état récupère le reste nous assurons
la communication de manière entièrement
libres sans contrôle et le contenu c'est
à dire que vous servez uniquement de
véhicules c'est ça une serre aux
véhicules et nous assurerons la liberté
d'accès aux réseaux avec 5 millions
d'appels par an pour le téléphone rose
et cent mille heures de connexion sur le
minitel par mois le groupe téléphone est
l'un des trusts du fantasme la recette
est simple un appartement de 100 m²
quelques minitel d'été les animatrices
et l'exploitation intelligente des
délires d'autrui le minitel est un
service public
je veux dire aujourd'hui il ya en ile de
france deux personnes sur trois qui sont
des solitaires grâce au minitel ils vont
avoir possibilité de se rencontrer
le minitel est complètement jeu direct
rance trans sociale si on en voit
uniquement je dirais l'aspect très
limité q la superbe je dirais sordide
que peut avoir parfois le minitel c'est
3% du minitel les dérapages sont
pourtant inévitable mais l'été les
animatrices sont là pour veiller au
grain attention ce qui n'est pas un jeu
des prostituées qui ont fait déjà arrivé
c'est déjà arrivé et m'a fait quoi dans
ces cas-là on déconnecte
c'est à dire qu'on s'en sorte que leur
minitel s'éteignent rien ne peut
cependant pour l'instant empêcher un
enfant d'accéder aux messageries
érotique
on peut s'interroger et si à travers ce
nouveau mode de communication
il ne revient pas il n'est pas
nécessaire de repenser complètement
l'organisation juridique pour protéger
la jeunesse
l'idée me semble-t-il n'est pas
d'interdire mais de permettre une
diffusion beaucoup plus restreinte
un peu comme en matière de cinéma pour
les films tact et x films
pornographiques
on peut toutefois se demander s'il est
techniquement possible d'interdire le
minitel aux moins de 16 ans
deux petits avions ultra léger motorisé
des ulm se sont posés en fin d'après
midi au pôle nord géographique hubert de
chevigny et nicolas hulot ont tous
réussi dans leur tentative ils sont les
premiers à avoir rejoint ce qu'on
appelle le toit du monde
en ulm claude crespo
les loups du grand nord n'en reviennent
pas d ulm au paul ça ne s'était jamais
vu et paris tenus pour les deux français
qui ont réussi à joindre le toit du
monde le pôle nord géographique en avion
ultra léger motorisé les costes et
bellonte version banques qu'ils se sont
eux nicolas hulot et son compère hubert
de chevigny auteur d'un exploit d'autant
plus inespéré aujourd'hui qu'hier encore
il était bloqué à 450 km de là mais la
soirée relativement clémente -12 degrés
quand même a permis un nouveau départ
vers l'étape finale avec seulement 18
litres d'essence chacun les vainqueurs
ont bien ils l'ont fait savoir par radio
mais le retour sera tributaire d'un
troisième avion ils attendent maintenant
un appareil ravitailleurs pour revenir
au camp de base
à la rédaction d'antenne 2 nous avons
décidé de rendre hommage à dalida ce
soir et pour cela nous avons essayé de
rassembler des témoignages des extraits
de films des documents sur dalida avec
jean michel boris qui est directeur de
l'olympia avec hervé vilard nicoletta
nous verrons peut-être la carrière de
chanteuse et puis la manière dont vous
les fréquenter avec deluxe on verra un
peu tout cet aspect professionnel avec
les instants d'émotions vous avez pu
vivre avec elle je sais que vous la
connaissiez tous très bien et puis nous
rejoindrons tout à l'heure youssef
chahine le réalisateur égyptien qui
avait tourné avec dalida son dernier
film sixième jour il ya quelques mois à
peine
dalida était venu ici d'ailleurs pour en
parler veron et avec youssef chahine
cette carrière de comédienne qu'elle
avait suivi dans six films très
exactement je crois nous verrons avec
youssef chahine
après à la fin de cette édition spéciale
dalida avait 54 ans elle était donc une
une chanteuse une actrice elle fêtait
cette année ses trente ans de métier
j'ai retrouvé une phrase qu'elle avait
confié mes collègues de france soir je
ferai mes adieux en l'an 2000 et bien on
pourrait lui reprocher pas de ne pas
avoir tenu sa promesse
elles laissent des chansons je vous en
propose trois extraits maintenant
pas
l'antenne
j'ai eu tort
mais là
d'entre eux
elle
il chantait
la talonnade
oh
selon
les gars
celle qui fait
pour ta vous
qui parle d'eux
géant américain a battu de vigan doigt
les temps
jean michel borys à l'olympia vous aviez
connu que les débuts tirait de dalida
tout à fait tout à fait comment ça
s'était passé cette première rencontre
d'hier avec rien ils ont été bruno
beatrix m'avait demandé c'est un an gta
olympiens allaient demander de faire une
expérience d'une audition publique et
nous avions réalisé une audition
publique et des gens fument inconnu et
au milieu de ces gens là s'était
présenté une grande jeune femme brune
très très typé avec une robe blanche
vêtue à l'antique et c'était dalida et
il se trouve que ce jour là dans un bar
situé à côté l'olympia et il y avait
lucien maury directeur d'europe numéro
et eddie barclay qui ont décidé comme ça
par hasard de venir faire un tour
cette audition qui n'avait rien de
sensationnel en soi et puis ils sont
tombés sur dalida et je crois qu est ce
que ça fait tout de suite c'est sa voix
c'est c'est une manière de deux chemins
on perd ça vous savez au départ dalida
c'est bien connu ne chantait pas très
juste mais c'était surtout le personnage
elle avait une aura que l'on est on
appelle une aura une présence alors là
il est la rencontre avec lucien morisse
très importante pour dalida parce que là
elle s'est mariée et us à maurice
ensuite vous avez vu évoluer d'allibert
comment là elle a toujours aimé vous
savez nous avons engagé je crois deux
ans après en américaine du spectacle
gilbert bécaud qui ouvrait le nouvel
olympia
c'était en 57 et il faut bien dire qu'à
ce moment là déjà des dida était un
personnage exceptionnel puisque je crois
que dans son tour de chant elle
possédait jusqu'à une dizaine de tubes
ce que l'on appelle des tuiles terre des
chansons que tout le monde chantait
c'est quand même une situation très
exceptionnelle elle est passée ensuite
deux ou trois ans plus tard et dans les
mêmes conditions puisqu'elle a été une
vendeuse de disques absolument est
considérable je crois que guy lux est
mieux placé que moi encore pour parler
de ce problème on règle lorsqu'il est il
ya une question quand même pourquoi est
ce qu'elle n'a pas fait l'olympia depuis
si cette invention dernier passage ses
80 mais elle avait fait le palais des
sports avec un tout un spectacle et l'a
repris ce spectacle quelques mois plus
tard le lundi
et puis depuis je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est passé je pense qu'elle avait envie
de faire une rentrée importante alors
vous savez on établit toujours des
distances entre de rentrer à paris
et puis les distances sont petit à petit
a grandi et puis peut-être que l' envie
et on ré et puis donc les problèmes
humains ont commencé à exister je pense
que si elle avait des problèmes comme
vous avez dit je crois de solitude celui
fait l'armée villach vous avez été aidé
à avons déduit par dalida mais je dois
vous parler de bon appareil de l'artiste
vais vous parler de cette grande femme
de coeur cg j'ai passé mon enfance en
orphelinat et lorsque j'étais en off
line array noël j'avais toujours un
petit mot de dalida ça me réchauffe est
bien le coeur et lorsque je j'ai débuté
dans ce plu en protéines comme rose
pendant ce voyage y avait beaucoup
j'étais un fan départ et puis je suis
resté là et ensuite lorsque j'ai
enregistré mon premier disque lorsque
j'ai eu mon premier livre dans les mains
dalida passé à bobino et je suis allé la
voir avec beaucoup d'espoir et le
lendemain j'ai entendu mon disque à la
radio vous imaginez ce que c'est pour un
jeune chanteur pour quelqu'un qui qui
débute
vous avez eu l'impression qu'elle était
un petit peu quelqu'un qui vous
permettait dire de mettre totalement de
lui apporter
elle m'a portée est il une tradition qui
se perd dans ce métier mais lorsque nous
entrions dans ce métier nous avions un
parrain et marraine et moi j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir maurice chevalier comme
parrain et dalida comme marraine je dis
souvent que ma famille est dans le
métier et ce soir chez je partage la
tristesse est votre analyse la grille
régulièrement elle a continué à vous
parler à vous dire hervé foutu face
savent toujours gérer des petits mots
lorsque je passais dans l'émission de
guy ou d'autres ou qu'elle me voyait au
bout du monde à les chanter
mais sicobois hier elle ment rennais
toujours des petits mots pour
m'encourager et pour me dire qu'elle
était là si j'avais besoin de quoi que
ce soit et vous l'avez vous allez
continuer à prendre un peu pour modèle
lorsque vous faisiez des spectacles vous
avez vous êtes inspirés des loupes non
je me suis pas inspiré du tout mais si
j'admire est son professionnalisme et la
force qu'elle avait malgré cette
solitude elle parlait d'elle on peut
avez vous beaucoup beaucoup elle se
confiait beaucoup par écrit ou le soir
voilà vous avez gardé une impression une
image très forte des choses très fort
belle très fort c'est très très très
fort c'est quelqu'un qui m'a beaucoup
donné et elle est dans mon coeur pour
toujours
nico les tables vous avez aussi je
dirais bien connu des rites à mes débuts
elle vous êtes même on m'a dit un peu
déconseillé de faire ce métier non c'est
pas ça va un peu fort que j'ai connus
dalida c'était en 67 je n'ai signé dans
la même compagnie discale elle était la
plus grande star de la maison et on m'a
emmené la voir en galas et c'est la
première chanteuse populaire que je
voyais sur scène parce que piaf était
déjà morte et il y avait quarante mille
personnes qui l'attendaient c'était à
grenoble et je me souviens avait quelque
chose qui n'allait pas bien pour la
technique alors elle s'est énervée elle
est partie comme une furie dans les
coulisses elle acheté le micro sous
l'oreille du pianiste et elle m'a
poussée contre les murs beiges
m'intéresse c'est de là que faire ce
métier qui veut faire ce métier et on
s'est revus bien sûr puisque on passait
des grandes soirées shelly barclay
c'était beaucoup de paternalisme çelebi
et un jour quand elle a chanté au palais
des congrès moi je trouve qu'il est
beaucoup trop de playback et lui demande
je suis quelqu'un un peu nature et qui
parle un peu trop fort je voyageais
supplée mac
évidemment certains journaux avaient
repris mes propos et une façon assez
plus violente que la mienne et je m'en
allais excusé c'est bien évident parce
que tout le monde aide
là c'est une famille merveilleuse elle
avait pardonné bien sûr mais je pense
que ce qui est dommage c'est que tout le
monde aime dalida dans votre milieu
ce qui est vrai mais je crois que tout
le monde la mal aimée vous avez chanté
une chanson qui s'appelait la solitude
n'existe pas on y pense en me souvenant
de la phrase qui a laissé dalida et
effectivement cette notion de solitude
hervé vous vous la ressentez
régulièrement
moi je ne suis pas seul match et j'ai
une famille que je protège beaucoup
bon tout le monde aime que je joue si
tout le monde sait que j'aime beaucoup
ma grand-mère bon je me prépare
évidemment à certaines choses mais je
sais un enfant je crois que l'un des
drames de dali j'avais présenté mon
enfant fréquente et jeunes ont convenu
homogène coiffeur et elle était très
admiratif devant mon petit bout de chou
et je sais que ça ça compte aussi
beaucoup dans sa vie de femme je crois
que la vida us de cliquer qu'elle est
devenue chanteuse enfin toute sa
carrière où le public l'a su aussi elle
a eu des drames terribles auxquelles
elle dut faire face elle l'a fait avec
beaucoup de dignité
je crois que c'est une femme exemplaire
en tag fans j'admire aussi beaucoup dali
donc tant que femme non seulement en
tant que star mais parce que sa carrière
beaucoup d'impressions de la haine mais
en tant que femme c'était quelqu'un de
vraiment très fort et très digne dalida
et est arrivé à paris en 1956 il
habitait depuis 24 ans à mon arbre alors
patrice vanelle alexandre pour antenne 2
sont allés recueillir quelques
témoignages aujourd'hui près du domicile
de david à
une grande maison au coeur de montmartre
et devant des dizaines d'admirateurs
tout au long de la journée
certains arrivés très tôt ce matin dès 7
heures simplement pour regarder en
silence se parler à voix basse de leur
idole disparue j'adore david hâle la
connais depuis 30 ans de 1955 56 pour
moi c'était pas une synthèse
c'était une amie je suis personnellement
oui personnellement je peux vous dire
que dans cette maison j'ai vu beaucoup
champagne chez moi j'ai beaucoup de
gâteaux 40000 tézier étrangers et c'est
triste pour certains un geste symbolique
pendant que d'autres guetter le facteur
et ses liasses de télégrammes des fans
anonymes des curieux aussi venu pour
apercevoir une vedette s'engouffrer
derrière le grand portail vert mais les
personnalités du showbiz se sont faites
discrètes aujourd'hui peu de fleurs et
de visites rude hors champ seul françois
valéry et jacques attali qui sont venus
rendre un dernier hommage à dalida
pour pascal sevran son ami de toujours
un drame prévisible dès que j'ai sujet
première chose que j'ai déjà dit ce que
c'était
obligé
il y avait quelque chose de brisé et
c'est chez cette femme depuis l'enfance
mais personne n'a jamais su si c'était
elle parle de la solitude
assez peu assez peu assez peu elle
faisait semblant de rire
nostalgie souvenirs personnes
aujourd'hui sur le pavé de montmartre ne
voulait accepter la fatalité la
disparition de dalida
après 30 ans de succès monsieur jacques
chirac a envoyé un télégramme de
condoléances au frère de dalida il salue
une très grande dame de la chanson
française et puis le président de la
république adresse également un
télégramme il part d'une femme de coeur
généreuse et malheureuse
guy lux vous avez vous j'irais
accompagné toute la vie professionnelle
de dalida
oui en fait d'ailleurs ça m'a un petit
peu ému de voir cette maison parce que
j'étais hier soir bien sûr à toute
allure je suis aller retour et son frère
qui était dans un état épouvantable
parce que c'était tout pour dalida et
dalila étaient tous pour son frère mais
la dent dernière fois j'avais été dans
cette maison c'était bon jouent aux
cartes on se retrouvait souvent samedi
soir dimanche soir dans des parties de
cartes et freiner partie de rami ou
d'ailleurs dalida trichet parce que
c'était un jouet des haricots et elle
était assez d'eau et depuis quelques
mois il n'y avait plus partie car c'est
ça c'est un signe
c'était le signe d'une évolution une
sorte de déprime elle était seule était
seul entouré d'une foule d'amis parce
qu' hier leur ai donné un simple coup de
téléphone s'il était en détresse et à
des prix bien eu 250 amis pour venir
l'été mais comme le dit tout à l'heure
hervé je pense pas qu'ils aient une dame
de la chanson grande dame de la chanson
qui avait autant d'amis parce que les à
la une une carrière rectiligne sans
faille toujours droit toujours amicales
une amitié sincère amitié authentique
comme on en rencontre peu dans notre
métier faut bien le reconnaître
alors il est évident qu'elle avait
beaucoup d'amis et c'est qu'elle n'ait
pas fait un appel au secours et à son
staff est anormal mais d'alizay était
une femme de contrastes elle triche elle
s'amusait au car elle était absolument
farouches comme l'a dit tout à l'heure
nicole sur les studios sur les plateaux
et puis par contre elle elle qui
arrivait toujours comme drapé dans une
espèce de dignité qui faisait d'ailleurs
son extrême charme à la télévision parce
que quand elle arrivait on se demandait
d'où elles sortent et s'ils sortaient
des mains d'un coiffeur des madame à qui
elle avait toujours quelque chose à fait
inattendue mais un quart d'heure avant
l'avait vu sur le plateau en répétition
avec tous ses bigoudis c'était
d'ailleurs la seule je crois du métier à
venir avec 150 bigot
dans les cheveux se moquant complètement
du qu'en dira-t-on ça c'est tout dalida
on va voir guilde alida comédienne leïla
actrice elle était donc égyptienne je
voulais 10 et en 54 elle devient miss
egypte et puis on la voit pour la
première fois dans un petit film vous
allez en voir un extrait et je vais
rejoindre ensuite youssef chahine
suite de voir un extrait du sixième jour
de youssef chahine
c'est donc dalida d'un dernière regardez
bien moi
jésus lui connaît
youssef chahine merci d'être venu vous
arrivez du caire notre confrère du monde
par de dalida l'égyptienne c'était
effectivement quelqu'un qui était très
marquée par ses origines
enfin c'est peut-être un signe et ptet
de effet ce film juste avant de me
quitter
si vous laisser voir chez nous comme
comment la considérer ce qu'elle était
en tant qu'egyptien l'égyptienne qui a
réussi à paris les voiles sont calqués
quand il a reçu il ya quelques mois à
rennes c'était une foule en délire il
est pleinement dans la vie c'est
absolument merveilleux je suis lequel
qu'elle ait connu cela au début connu ça
juste avant de partir parce que elle le
méritait elle a été extraordinaire et je
crois que la quête très heureuse pendant
le tournage du film
c'était aussi une actrice aussi une
comédienne c'était surtout une
tragédienne et ados pitt depuis
longtemps que je voulais faire savoir
c'est que c'était une personne tellement
sensible et qui avait tellement du
métier elle avait tellement de rigueur
dans dans le métier
jeudi c'est dommage que ce soit aussi
c'est simplement l'autre il fallait
aussi quand on la découvre aussi les
mamans gelé toulouse senti pendant des
années et des années
cette simplicité qui est d'une force
extraordinaire élevé merci youssef
chahine vous être déplacés je sais que
c'est pas facile de parler d'une amie
surtout lorsque cet ami a décidé de nous
quitter
merci nous allons redonner ce témoignage
de témoignages de dalida
la comédienne on va la ré entendre une
dernière fois dis moi que je t'aime
c'est petit de sa chanson dalida
o qui chauffe eau
ok c'est bon
oh non
un champ
ok
faux
paupières c
c'est grand
que de voeux
quand
dans ce
et
non
daddy dame météo nous existons un combat
des titans à une à combat entre un
anticyclone in dépression nous allons
voir tout de suite cela sur l'image
satellite avec un anticyclone qui située
sur l'atlantique
une dépression juste au dessus de la
corse et les nuages son rôle dans le
sens inverse de 7,2 legs des aiguilles
d'une montre et redescendre vers le sud
et l'est du pays
tempête de neige aujourd'hui sur l'est
et demain ce seront encore du très
mauvais temps mauvais temps de l'alsace
et la bourgogne limousin pyrénées côte
d'azur et corse avec des nuages de la
pluie de la neige du vent des orages en
revanche de très belles éclaircies sur
le flanc ouest
et puis un ciel très nuageux sur l'axé
central les températures demain elles
seront en légère hausse de 9 à 14 degrés
sur la moitié nord et de 9 à 17 degrés
sur la moitié sud
demain ce sera le mardi 5 mai le soleil
se lèvera 6h26 kousra 21h09 promis ni de
saillans plus et ce sera la sainte
judith 21h40 caméras deux spéciales
barbie en quête de daniel leconte 23h et
claude pour le dernier journal demain en
cours de télématin d'un cas de vérité
pierre juquin sera interrogé par paul
nahon à demain 20h bonsoir merci